well Germany is marking the 75th
anniversary of the liberation of book
involved one of the second world wars
most notorious concentration camps a
commemoration was planned at the site of
the camp but because of the current
restrictions on public gatherings a
virtual remembrance ceremony is being
held instead one of the last remaining
survivors tells us his story walking
violet concentration camp April 1945
shortly after the liberation it was one
of the biggest death camps on German
soil from 1937 to 1945 the Nazis
imprisoned more than 260,000 people here
even even II survived the death camp as
a young Jew he was imprisoned in one of
the many separate forced labor camps
April the 11th the floodlights went dark
the SS were gone from afar we heard the
rumble of cannon ah nobody dared move
many more were dying there had been no
food for days only the next day some of
the Russian prisoners went outside
what are you later
we marched my [ __ ] 56,000 people were
murdered at boot invaded or died of
starvation or illness
after the liberation of the death camp
the American soldiers forced citizens of
nearby vemma to visit the site to face
the atrocities the corpses were piled up
remembering the atrocities remains
important seventy-five years on but even
even he wants to look forward dinked and
be mentioned a while think of the ones
who are suffering today who are fleeing
fleeing a war or because they hope to
find their paradise elsewhere those who
drown in the ocean who are stuck between
borders don't tell me that this is
something different
of course it is a little different but a
lot of people turned a blind eye when it
came to what happened with the Jews so
if you've got the strength and show
empathy for those who need help no even
even ye is grateful for all the heavy
years he has lived since his liberation
he knows life could have ended very
differently today victims are remembered
at the Buchenwald Memorial on the site
of the former concentration camp